it's great to be joined today by James
Jenkins who is a professor of
astrophysics at the University of Chile
and one of the team members who
discovered Proxima be an earth-mass
exoplanet around the nearest star to our
solar system so let's start with the
logistics I mean even from my
explanation what is the nearest star to
our solar system people may not know
that and what is an exoplanet okay so
then the nearest star to the Sun it's
called Proxima be air Proxima Centauri
and it's orbited by Proxima be and as
you just as you just mentioned and
Proxima Centauri is a very small star in
comparison to the Sun possible say one
tenth of the size of our Sun and is much
cooler
it's called is known as a red dwarf star
or an m-type star and we're finding a
lot about these types of stars they're
the most common stars in the galaxy they
make up about 70% of the stars in the
galaxy which is likely to be one of the
reasons the Proxima is the closest star
just because these are the most abundant
stars that exist and as you said it's
orbited by a nearby a small planet
called Proxima B and this is a an
exoplanet and weird of these things
exoplanets because they orbit stars
other than the Sun so any planet outside
of our solar system that's not let's say
gravitationally bound to our Sun is
called an exoplanet or extrasolar planet
okay good so when we talk about
exoplanet although much media attention
is on exoplanets that may be in some way
earth-like the term exoplanet does not
tell us anything about the type of
planet that it is or how similar or
different to earth that is all it means
is it is part of a different solar
system exactly that's exactly what it
means it just means it's outside the
solar system so it tells us
nothing about what type of planet is but
it just tells us it's not part of our
brothers and sisters if you're like it's
not part of the solar system ok let's
talk about the distance from us of
Proxima be 4 light-years from us in some
way it's very very difficult to really
conceptualize how far that is and of
course we can say well 4 light-years is
the distance it takes the distance light
can travel in 4 years but is there some
other analogy that we can think about to
really conceptualize what distance we're
talking about here yes interesting
question because 4 light years seems
like a small distance when we when we
think I mean it's the number 4 it's a
small number however in reality 4 light
years is an incredibly large distance
it's as the the distance that light can
travel in one year now that may mean
even less but this the speed of light is
the ultimate speed that will like
velocity in the universe by 300 million
meters per second I feel like so let's
try and make this into something more
palatable understandable and so light
takes about 8 and a half or so minutes
to travel between the Sun and the earth
however then it takes about another 4
years to reach Proxima Proxima B or
Proxima Centauri and for instance if
when you switch your your light on and
your house
one full thorn of light for like one
pocket of energy can travel around the
earth more than seven times in just one
second so that's some way to try and
think about the speed of light takes
about eight and a half minutes or so to
travel between the Sun and the earth but
then takes another
4.2 years just to reach Proxima Centauri
so now that you've told us just how far
four light years is what is also
interesting about this discovery is that
this is actually the closest exoplanet
to the earth so given how far it is
the fact that it is the closest does it
open up any opportunities to I mean I'll
throw out the question of traveling
there but I think a more realistic
question would be getting actual imaging
of the planet at some point I mean how
far off is that yes exactly so this is
the great one of the great features of
this discovery I mean we're never going
to discover another planet closer than
the próxima be them around a star like
Proxima Centauri so so this is the great
hope the very soon we're talking about
our teams in the near future we may be
able to use some of these next
generation of instrumentation and
next-generation telescopes both in space
and on the ground to try to understand
more about Proxima B and of course the
great hope for everybody is that we can
in the near future get a direct damage
and that being able to image it directly
something very powerful because then we
can do things we can start to understand
the atmosphere the chemistry in the
atmosphere and and where the future came
the goal of looking for for life
for instance and particular or following
the water looking for liquid water these
these kinds of studies that we can
perform now the separation between the
two because the star is so close the the
separation is normally the big problem
but that's not the case in this case it
can be done with a small telescope
something at the moment we can separate
the star with things telescopes of
diameters of around 3 meters or so we
can actually we can actually separate
them the problem is the planet will be
incredibly faint compared to the
brightness of the star so that's
something to overcome but 7 that we have
ideas we have new telescopes new
instrumentation coming online in the
very near future the we we believe that
this will be possible and I want to say
the 10 to 20 year time frame that's one
of the hopes so talk a little bit about
I mean you mentioned the that we're
talking about a smaller and cooler star
here in Proxima Centauri you're talking
about a planet
is closer to that star what do you know
about either and you may maybe you don't
know anything about these things but
I'll throw out a few characteristics to
you the estimated temperature on the
surface of the planet as well as what in
earth time would be a year on this
planet that's a good point because one
of the other great well number one we
know a lot about the star the star has
been studied for many years given us
that it's the closest star however it's
not the brightest star as I said as
small it's cool but it's bright enough
that it was discovered in the early 20th
century and so it's been very heavily
studied and very searched for planets as
well we've been looking for planets for
many years with no detections just
because of no we know the planet is very
small and exempts and not a great
influence on its star so it was very
difficult to detect and that's one of
the key points but the other key point
is that also the planet is located in a
region we call the habitable zone now
that's thus a ring around the star we
are if we take an earth-like planet
something that we believe similar to
earth and we place at this distance from
the star that would be able to maintain
liquid water on the surface
hmm and this is one of the key goals for
for looking for future places for air
for life so it to exist outside of our
solar system and so we actually know
what the equilibrium temperature if we
say that's that what the temperature on
the surface of the planet could be but
it's very dependent on what the planet
actually is made of does it have an
atmosphere or doesn't know now if it has
an atmosphere that's similar to the
Earth's at some level then we can be
quite confident it could have liquid
water on its surface they never have a
temperature very similar to the earth
and but again this comes back to the one
of the great questions and not as does
Proxima B have any atmosphere at all
there are some people who when they hear
about such a discovery
we'll say if there were intelligent life
on this planet we would be able to
ascertain that today in 2016 from Earth
therefore because we haven't heard
anybody like James Jenkins or anybody
else tell us there's life on this planet
we can be sure that there is no life on
this planet is that true I mean is there
or is that a total myth that we would we
would already know whether this was a
planet with life on it yes a very
interesting question and a difficult
question to answer it's very dependent
on what the complexities of that life
would be in the sense that so we we try
to listen for instance for strong
directed radio signals this is what one
great part of the SETI project that they
used big radio telescopes to try to
listen and on but but what are listening
for specifics very specific need to be
strong radio signals even directed radio
signals and they also look for light
pulsation laser pulsations that may be
shot out by some civilization and so I
wouldn't say at this moment that we
could be confident that we could rule
out even an advanced civilization on on
Proxima B and of course this is this is
highly speculative my part and but and
and my mind what we're really going to
look for is to try to follow the follow
the war and then hopefully we can study
the atmosphere to look for potential
evidence of smaller life well it's
absolutely fascinating James before we
go what's it like in the room when this
discovery takes place or is that even
you know people imagine it where one
second you don't know about Proxima B
and then all of a sudden you do and
everybody rejoices in happiness but is
it like that or is it really a lot of
reviewing data and math etc and and the
existence of this planet is sort of
slowly revealed to you
yes so these came the these came the
discoveries can come in two forms we are
one you get an image maybe you're
working on on spacecraft they are
whatever you get an image of something
you see it and wow there's something
that jumped so straight over you and
that's something incredible and when you
that's when you cry a crack out the
champagne and the office however this
was a different type of discovery in the
sense that that's took sex it was 16
years of observations now we we actually
had both points both types of alike of
discovery as part of this project
because because we were using data that
was observed by both ourselves and other
groups that were in the archives and so
we mined the archive first so it was
kind of like we jumped 13 years into the
future if you like we had a a massive
data set from 13 years before and then
we analyzed that and that's when we see
in a second all emerge
so there was a kind of moment where we
one second we didn't know in the next
second Wow is potentially something
there but then we had to conform it
because it we were nowhere near 100%
sure on our or assured as we needed to
be to publish the planet and so that
took another project then they took
another few months and we were getting
the day off every night coming in and it
was being analyzed night by night and
each night we were seeing that the
signal continued to get stronger and
stronger so that was a more slower
Bannen process but but yeah um still
caused us of course to crack open a
bottle of champagne at the end because
that's good real eventually got this to
the champagne no matter what and I think
for that with all the grateful we've
been speaking with James Jenkins
professor of astrophysics at the
University of Chile joining us today
from Scotland thank you so much for
talking to me today thank you